[Musique]
c'est dans un studio d'enregistrement
que se finalise la production d'un cd 2
titres sur les droits de l'enfant
cette rencontre réunit les enfants du
but et les travailleurs sociaux du
département
dans le cas de dette sociale à l'enfance
hall opportunités que nous avons eues
cité
la joie ni des droits de l'enfant c'est
le 20 novembre
c'est une journée qui est au delà du
département c'est nationale même
international et on a voulu justement
sensibiliser les jeunes sur les droits
le droit à
ils ont des devoirs mais ils ont aussi
des dodos des droits et à partir de là
nous avons commencé avec l'aide de
michael un jeune artiste est copié
reconnu maintenant internationalement
comment justement mettre en mots et en
musique
le droit est aussi bas parler aussi de
leur souffrance malheureusement puisque
ça en existe mais aussi beaucoup d'amour
et beaucoup d'espoirs
ce sont pas moins de 20 par an dix
enfants quinze adolescents lui
professionnels du département et quatre
musiciens qui ont participé à la
réalisation de singles cette action
s'articule autour de l'écriture du texte
et de la musique et a pour objectif
remettre les jeunes au coeur de la
société et de l'avenir
on l'a mis sa sous forme d'une histoire
l'histoire du poupet pour dire que on
est pas des poupées justement qu'on veut
vivre notre vie avec nos propres
expériences et pas pour mascate et déjà
ses 20 ans le studio du conte et des
buts ans et c'est une première
expérience pour certains d'entre nous et
donc après des paroisses était plutôt
facile
enfin a dit tout ce qu'on avait sur le
coeur et bourse étaient plus faciles et
accompagné de l'artiste michael les
enfants ont pu gérer leurs fesses et
prendre confiance et de la musique c'est
parce que me considère que la musique
n'est pouvoir il me voit que ce pouvoir
là des fonctions chebana et c'est
possible en poursuivant le projet c'est
que nous l'a pu pas forcément parce que
nous témoignent que seulement le
mercredi donc nous n'avons pas ce
rapprochement là il fallait bien mon
travail c'est de faire des vidéos de
coeur donc ces enfants ces jeunes là est
sa devise au coeur desquelles on ne
connaît pas c'est pour ça que la musique
est ea vient qu'on la place des sujets
est la seul a pu écrire il fait des
choses des carrément incroyable
impossible de vous dire je t'aime
[Musique]